When my husband turned to me this morning
and said he was craving steak and fries,
I knew exactly where to take him,
since this little restaurant in Paris only serves those two things.
Luckily, it was only a 15 minute walk from our hotel,
and the line in front of the restaurant moved pretty quickly.
There was no food menu, since they only served steak and fries.
They immediately brought us out this mustardy green salad.
They asked us how we wanted our steak cooked.
About 10 minutes later, it was served.
Place actually surprised me.
I didn't think it was gonna be good,
and even though it needed a little bit of salt,
the sauce was amazing. Not only with the fries and the meat,
but also the bread. After the first two rounds of steak,
they said that's all they served,
so we had to order another portion since lucky was really hungry still.
But at this point, I was stuffed.
So he finished off my steak and fries before he tapped out.
And after he paid, we needed something sweet,
so we found this little crepe stand.
I obviously got the crepe with lemon and sugar
before we headed back to the hotel.